[Music]
get ready to dive into the battlefield
in for honor master the medieval
weaponry as the bold Knights brutal
Vikings and lethal samurai prepare for
vicious fast-paced melee combat and
become the ultimate warrior but which of
the three legendary factions will you
choose here's what you need to know to
win glory as the samurai brought to you
by for honor the samurai have endured a
tragic history of a homeland lost to sea
and fire they have now built a new
empire near the lands of the Vikings and
the Knights though they remain
outnumbered by their neighbors they must
rely on their greater martial skill and
cunning to survive as the last of their
kind enjoining the samurai of the dawn
Empire you select from heroes that have
spent their lives fighting and training
and possess an unbreakable will you get
the chance to wield katanas Spears or
clubs Master the samurai in order to
defeat the Knights and the Vikings
here's what we know about the samurai
subclasses so far the Ken se are masters
of multiple martial arts and are medium
level samurai they are balanced samurai
armed with heavy armor and the new da
Chi a longer version of the katana they
are slower than other units but have a
longer melee range ken say our excellent
mid-range heavy fighters thanks to their
long katanas they deal heavy damage and
our semi fast attackers with a good
amount of health compared to other heavy
heroes they can't stay in battle for
long periods of time and they don't pack
the same punishment taking health damage
luring enemies into closed off spaces
allows for your longsword to strike them
at a safe distance keeping you away from
their attack range for example the
Knights peacekeeper is a dangerous open
area fighter but corner her in a closed
in space and the no dachi will do the
rest
the Kensei combine their light attacks
with finishing heavy swings serving as
one of the best offensive heavy heroes
on the field
shigeki are easy level disruptor tanks
they may appear slow and cumbersome but
are incredibly strong and can absorb
many hits
shigeaki are armed with the pen a bow a
traditional club that can deliver a
crippling blow the tank on the field
shigeaki packed the heaviest damage
dealing weapon with the highest health
of any hero should go PR best at
clearing the way for their team due to
high damage capabilities and health the
shigeki are the slowest moving and
fighting heroes they have an easy tell
on their swing attacks that can be
blocked quickly and they take longer to
cross the field from point A to B tchy
goki are best when used as a stationary
fighter when taking on the power of the
Knights warden the brute strength of the
shego key will crush her armor with just
a few heavy swings let the enemy come to
you by luring them to unclaimed capture
points or by leading them to their
allies body waiting to be revived any
enemy you face will have to be at the
top of their game in order to survive
your power
the Orochi are the Imperial assassins of
the samurai they are trained in the arts
of stealth and deception armed with
light armor and a katana
they have strong counter-attacks but
requires skill and timing to have an
effective defense the Orochi are beloved
as one of the best light characters with
high damage quick movement and attack
speed
much like the peacekeeper and berserkers
the Orochi specialize in hit-and-run
tactics with the ability to sneak behind
enemy lines to capture points or to help
finish a fleeing foe due to such low
armor health the Orochi can't stay in a
chaotic fight for too long despite
having fast blocking the Orochi should
avoid being outnumbered when teamed up
with heavy allied heroes they combine to
make one of the best combo tag teams on
the battlefield masters of strengths
such as the Vikings carry the rage but
with the combined swiftness of the ero
cheese blade and feet they can run
circles and slice any foe in half
the no bushi are elegant fighters that
move like the wind they are armed with
the naginata a long versatile weapon
with a curved blade they had the
lightest armor making them fast but
unable to take a lot of damage the Nobu
she is a zone character she tries to
keep her distance while constantly
pestering any attackers she has the
longest attack range of the samurai and
has a fast revive the Nobu she has the
weakest armor in the samurai ranks
support roles and hit-and-run tactics
best suit her in combat her naginata is
excellent for keeping enemies at a
distance use her light attacks comboed
with a few heavy attacks on your foes be
warned her heavy attacks can easily be
parried leaving her vulnerable it only
takes a few heavy attacks to bring her
down pledge your sword to the samurai of
the dawn Empire and join the war of the
factions who will reign supreme be sure
to check out our other videos to learn
about the other factions Knights and
Vikings brought to you by for honor for
honor is available on February 14 2017
and for all your for honor needs stick
with GameSpot